allow me to please return to The Human
Condition and one of the nice features
of the human condition is love
do you think humans will fall in love
with AI systems and maybe they with us
so that aspect of the Human Condition do
you think that will be affected
so in Greece there's many many words for
love
and some of them mean friendship some of
them mean passionate love some of them
mean fraternal love
Etc so um I think AI doesn't have the
baggage that we do
and it doesn't have you know all of the
subcortical regions that we kind of you
know started with before we evolved all
of the cognitive aspects so I would say
AI is Faking it when it comes to love
but when it comes to Friendship
when it comes to being able to be your
therapist your coach
your motivator someone who synthesizes
stuff for you who writes for you who
interprets a complex passage who
compacts down a very long lecture or a
very long text
I think that
friendship will definitely be there like
the the fact that I can have my
companion my partner my AI who has grown
to know me well and that I can trust
with all of the darkest parts of myself
all of my flaws all of the stuff that I
I only talk about to my friends and
basically say listen you know here's all
this stuff that I'm struggling with
someone who will not judge me who will
always be there to better me
in in some ways not having the baggage
might make for your best friend for your
you know your confidante
uh that that can truly help reshape you
so I do believe that human AI
relationships will absolutely be there
but not the passion
more the mentoring well this is a really
interesting thought to play Devil's
Advocate
if those AI systems are locked in
in faking the baggage
who are you to say that the AI systems
that begs you
not to leave it or it doesn't love you
who are you to say that this AI system
that writes poetry to you that is afraid
of death afraid of life without you
um or vice versa one you know uh creates
the kind of drama that humans create the
the power dynamics that can exist in a
relationship what AI system that is one
abusive one day and romantic the other
day all the different variations of
relationships and it's consistently that
it holds the full richness of a
particular personality why is that not a
system you can love in a romantic way
why is it faking it if it sure as hell
seems real there's many answers to this
the first is it's only the eye of the
beholder who tells me that I'm not
faking it either maybe all of these
subcortical systems that make me sort of
have different emotions
maybe they don't really matter maybe all
that matters is the neocortex and that's
where all of my emotions are encoded and
the rest is just you know bells and
whistles
um that's one possibility and and
therefore
you know who am I to judge that is
Faking it when maybe I'm faking it as
well
the second is neither of us is Faking it
maybe it's just an emergent behavior all
these neocortical systems that
is truly capturing the same exact
essence of love and hatred and
dependency and sort of you know reverse
psychology and
um
that that that we have so it is possible
that it's simply an immersion behavior
and that we don't have to encode these
additional architectures that all we
need is more parameters and some of
these parameters can be all of the
personality traits
a third option is that just by telling
me oh look now I've built an emotion
component to AI it has a limbic system
it has a lizard brain Etc
and suddenly I'll say oh cool it has the
capability of emotion so now when it
exhibits the exact same unchanged
behaviors that it does without it
I as the beholder
will be able to sort of attribute to it
emotional attributes that I would to
another human being and therefore have
that mental model of that other person
so again I think a lot of relationships
is about the mental models that you
project on the other person
and that they're projecting on you
and um
then yeah then in that respect I do
think that
even without the embodied intelligence
part without having ever experienced
what it's like to be heartbroken the
sort of cultural feeling of misery
um that that system you know I could
still attribute it
traits of human
feelings and emotions and in the
interaction with that system something
like love emerges so it's possible that
love is not a thing that exists in your
mind but a thing that
exists in the uh interaction of the
different mental models you have of
other people's minds or other person's
mind and so
you know it doesn't as long as one of
the entities let's just take the easy
case one of the entities is human and
the other is AI
it feels very natural that from the
perspective at least the human there is
a real love there
and then the question is how does that
transform Human Society if it's possible
that which I believe will be the case
I don't know what to make of it but I
believe they'll be the case where
there's
hundreds of millions of romantic
Partnerships between humans and AIS
what does that mean for society if you
look at longevity and if you look at
happiness and if you could look at late
life you know well-being
the love of another human
is one of the strongest indicators of
Health into long life
and I have many many countless stories
where as soon as the Romantic partner of
60 plus years of a person dies within
three four months the other person dies
just like losing their love I think the
concept of being able to satisfy that
emotional need that humans have even
just as a mental health sort of service
uh to me you know that's that's a very
good Society
it doesn't matter if your love is wasted
quote unquote on a machine
it is you know the placebo if you wish
that makes the patient better anyway
like there's nothing behind it but just
the feeling that you're being loved will
probably engender all of the emotional
attributes of that
the other story that I want to say in
this whole concept of Faking It
and maybe I'm a terrible dad but I was
asking my kids I was asking my my kids
I'm like
does it matter if I'm a good dad or does
it matter if I act like a good dad
in other words if I give you love and
shelter and kindness and warmth and all
of the above
you know does it matter that I'm a good
dad conversely if I deep down love you
to the end of Eternity but I'm always
gone yeah
which which dad would you rather have
the cold ruthless killer that will show
you only love and warmth and nourish you
and nurture you
or the amazingly warm-hearted but works
five jobs and you never see them
and what's the answer I mean I
think from I think you're a romantic so
you say it matters what's on the inside
but pragmatically speaking why does it
matter the fact that I'm even asking
asking the question basically says it's
not enough to love my kids I better
freaking be there to show them that I'm
there
so basically of course you know
everyone's a good guy in their story
yeah so in my story I'm a good dad
but if I'm not there it's wasted so the
reason why I ask the question is for me
to say
you know does it really matter that I
love them if I'm not there to show it
but it's also possible that what reality
is is the you showing it that what you
feel on the inside is
is little narratives and games you play
inside your mind it doesn't really
matter that the thing that truly matters
is how you act and in that
AI systems can quote unquote fake yeah
and that if it's all that matters is
actually real but not fake yeah yeah
again let there be no doubt I love my
kids to Pieces but you know my My worry
is am I being a good enough Dad yeah and
what does that mean like if I'm only
there to do their homework and make sure
that they you know do all the stuff but
I don't show it to them then you know
might as well be a terrible dad
but I agree with you that like if the AI
system can basically play the role of a
father figure
for many children that don't have one or
you know the role of parents or the role
of siblings
if a child grows up alone
maybe their emotional state will be very
different than if they grow up with an
AI sibling